[Music]
both Diablo 3 and sacred 3 have been
streamlined since their last games to
make couch co-op multiplayer easy to get
into though Diablo 3 is clearly the
better action RPG sacred 3 does some
interesting things to make that couch
co-op experience as painless as possible
so which is the better game of the you
and your friends to flop down on some
cushions with and cut a swath for some
fantasy voids in Diablo 3 each player on
the one console can log in with their
own PSN or XBLA character if someone
doesn't own the game themselves they can
create a new character that is stored
locally and boosted to the level of the
other players
now this local character only has its
stats scaled it still actually starts at
level 1 it can hold its own in a fight
but it can't actually use any of the
loot that it finds until it's quickly
leveled up alongside the rest of the
party sacred 3 gets around this because
the game only rewards new loot at the
end of each quest that specific weapon
will always be rewarded at the same time
for each individual character so there's
no need for that loot to have a level
requirement now because of this when you
make a local character in sacred 3 that
character only ever exists for that
session if you come back later you'll
need to make a new character again at
whatever level the party leader is at
but you'll still have the same items and
skills available to choose from for
couch co-op this works far better
Diablo 3 supports for players in couch
co-op while sacred 3 only supports 2 in
order to reach sacred 3 is a maximum
play account of 4 you need to be playing
online however you can still use the
second players locally created character
in online play thereby allowing 2 people
per console or per PC to play in a
single online game in Diablo 3 each
player on one console can log in with
their own PSN or XBLA character even if
they don't own the game they just need
that free PSN or Xbox Live account if
someone doesn't have an account they can
create a new character that is stored
locally and boosted to the level of the
other players for Diablo 3 on current
gen consoles at least one player needs
to have an xbox live gold or PlayStation
Plus subscription to let locally created
characters play in online games on ps3
playstation plus is not required and
local characters can play online without
any issues on xbox360 every player needs
their own Xbox Live Gold subscription to
play online otherwise the game will be
forced into land mode which means you
can't play against other people
depending on your setup these
restrictions could be limiting if you
and a buddy want to play against two
other distant friends so if your couch
only has space for one other friend then
you've set with sacred 3 but if you're
King sized sofa needs warming then only
Diablo 3 will give you that 4 player 5
in Diablo 3 only one player is able to
view their full inventory screen at a
time the entire game stops and other
players have to wait their turn this
gets old really fast to compensate you
can use the d-pad to cycle through new
items without bringing up the full
inventory window but not enough
information is shown so it's hard to
tell exactly what each item does it's
inevitable that each player will
eventually have to stop everything and
sort through their full inventory at
regular intervals sacred 3 streamlining
makes its own inventory management far
less of a headache for other players
because new items and skill modifiers
are only unlocked at the end of each
quest never during combat the game
provides a set moment for you to manage
your inventory and at the only time that
you ever need to manage it both players
in couch co-op mode can see and sort
through their own inventories on the
screen at the same time as each other
with no need to stop and take turns
while sacred 3 makes headway in the
inventory management space Diablo 3 does
a far better job of managing each
player's physical location the game will
smartly teleport any player who wanders
too far to the edge of the screen back
towards the rest of the party because
all players need to be careful on screen
this means that someone can get up to go
and get a snack and the other players
can continue exploring because the
absent player will be teleported along
with the group sacred 3 includes no such
system so if one player stands idle at
the edge of the screen the other player
will be completely unable to move
forward until they return
though Diablo 3 is a superior action RPG
to seek for three it's not the perfect
couch co-op game having four players
take on the primeval on the same console
makes for a great time but it's time
beset by constant inventory management
interruptions and the need for all
players to have their own characters for
the smoothest result but if you're
planning on playing with a single friend
then say for three streamlining still
makes for a fun couch co-op experience
[Music]